benzodiazepines are not usually offered  to kids too much today but definitely  older people are on them a lot a recent  study from france i just saw last week  showed that in this large sample of  french older people a third of them were  taking benzodiazepines which is actually  relatively low for france  but  45  of those people on benzodiazepine were  judged clinically dependent on  benzodiazepines which is a one of the  highest rates i've ever seen  meaning they apparently can't do without  the drug they're walking around with  doses in their purse they're having  withdrawal symptoms but geriatric  medicine has been one of the first ones  to implement deep prescribing cleaning  up people's medication regimen  because so many older people are on so  many drugs